aktuell kein Badespaß im kolumbiabad in
Berlin-Neukölln Sonntagabend eskalierten
hier Rangeleien die Polizei räumte das
Bad ein Thema selbst für die
Bundespolitik
das sind offensichtlich größere Gruppen
von
enthemmten Jugendlichen bei weitem nicht
nur mit Migrationshintergrund aber auch
mit Migrationshintergrund und hier kann
für alle gleichermaßen nur gelten hier
muss die Polizei eingreifen
seit Jahren geraten die Mitarbeiter im
Neuköllner Sommerbad immer wieder wegen
solcher Vorfälle wie hier im Juni 2014
an ihre Grenzen die Polizei sieht sich
nicht zuständig es ist nicht Aufgabe von
uns Polizistinnen und Polizisten die
Rutsche oder den Pool zu bewachen
sondern Gefahrenabwehr Strafverfolgung
da wo Schlägereien sind sind wir zur
Stelle und helfen aber vorher gibt es
andere die Arbeit leisten müssen
Gewalt im Freibad ein Problem das sind
ganz Deutschland auftaucht trotz
verstärkten security-einsatz allein in
Baden-Württemberg gab es vergangenen
Sommer
1174 erfasste Straftaten das ist zwar
weniger als vor der Pandemie aber
Körperverletzungen haben deutlich
zugenommen die Berliner Bäderbetriebe
kündigten unterdessen neue
Sicherheitsmaßnahmen an prüfen auch eine
Begrenzung der Besucherzahl mir ist
wichtig dass Familien in unserer Stadt
Kinder die jetzt Schulferien haben die
vielleicht nicht in den Urlaub fahren
können weil die Familien sich das nicht
leisten können dass sie schöne
Sommerferien haben und dafür brauchen
wir schöne aber vor allen Dingen auch
sichere Freibäder nach den
Auseinandersetzungen mit den
Jugendlichen haben sich viele
Mitarbeiter krank gemeldet und so bleibt
das kolumbierbad geschlossen bis auf
weiteres
das ist bei über 30 Grad und vielen
Menschen auf engem Raum zu Spannungen
kommen kann niemanden überraschen das
sagt Benjamin jendro von der
Gewerkschaft der Polizei was sagt der
Regierende Bürgermeister von Berlin Kai
Wegner von der CDU schön guten Morgen
guten Morgen das Problem ist ja nicht
neu also seit über zehn Jahren passiert
das immer und immer wieder und immer
wieder wird dann überlegt was kann man
eigentlich tun sie haben jetzt
kurzfristige Maßnahmen angekündigt was
konkret ich werde heute selbst an einem
Bad sein wo es immer wieder zu
Ausschreitung kommt gemeinsam mit der
innensenatorin ich will das Gespräch mit
den Bademeistern suchen aber auch mit
den Berliner Bäder betrieben und wir
müssen hierzu konkreten Maßnahmen kommen
konkrete Maßnahmen heißt ich möchte eine
mobile Wache von der Polizei an diesen
brennpunktbädern muss immer weil ja zur
Ausschreitung kommt das sind drei Bäder
in Berlin übrigens von über 60 hat dann
die meisten ist es ganz friedlich es
sind drei Bäder wir werden die
Sicherheitsdienste stärken und ich
glaube wir müssen zu einem besseren
Einlasssystem kommen Peter sind kein
rechtsfreier Raum haben sie ja schon ja
gesagt CDU-Chef Merz und auch die
Innenministerin Phaser die fordern mehr
Polizeipräsenz in den Bädern gehen Sie
da auch mit nein ich glaube die Polizei
muss in die Bäder wenn es zur
Ausschreitung kommt wenn es zu
Gewaltausbrüchen kommt Polizistinnen und
Polizisten sind ja keine
ersatzbademeister und das können die
auch gar nicht leisten ich glaube hier
sind die Bäderbetriebe gefordert über
Sicherheitsdienste und wir müssen im
Kassensystem im Eingangsbereich darauf
achten dass Straftäter die in der Regel
Wiederholungstäter sind gar nicht mehr
in die Bäder kommen wir müssen die
Hausverbote konsequent durchsetzen und
ich glaube das ist die Aufgabe der uns
jetzt stellen müssen Straftäter klar das
kann man über eine Ausweiskontrolle
Regeln Videoüberwachung ist noch eine
andere Idee aber oder die Obergrenze
also viele Bäder sind auch zu voll
darauf spielte glaube ich auch die
Aussage des Polizisten von der Polizei
Gewerkschaft an aber wenn sie sagen zum
Beispiel Einlass Kontrollen sie können
ja jemanden nicht vom Blick ins Gesicht
ansehen oder was jemand an hat oder was
auch immer ob der gewalttätig werden
würde also was sollen diese
Einlasskontrollen bringen wir hatten zu
corona-zeiten ja technische Mittel die
wir genutzt haben dass ich zum Beispiel
online ein Ticket bestellen musste wo
ich meinen Namen auch hinterlegen musste
und das kann man dann an der Kasse
überprüfen und wenn dann ein Straftäter
kommt der bekannt ist den lasse ich
nicht rein das ist klar aber gehen wir
mal weg von den Straftätern weil ich
kann mir nicht vorstellen dass jeder der
da jetzt auffällig geworden ist und
zugeschlagen hat auch im Vorfeld schon
Straftäter war also ist es dann eher
dass man den hinterher hafert werden
kann oder was soll das bringen na ich
muss erstmal die raushalten die immer
wieder auffällig sind das sind ja
oftmals Wiederholungstäter die muss ich
aus den Bädern raushalten die muss ich
mit Haus verboten belegen und dort wo
dann erst später sind die muss ich
Anzeigen die muss ich auch dann
bestrafen und beim nächsten Mal nicht
rein lassen und das muss jetzt
konsequent durchgesetzt werden und da
wollen sie das Sicherheit ganz Personal
aber auch unterstützen denn die sagen
wir sind total überfordert die
Hausverbote durchzusetzen aber auch
Anzeigen zu erstatten hier muss mehr
Personal rein hier sind auch die
Bäderbetriebe gefordert hier sind wir
auch als Politik gefordert das wird Geld
kosten aber dieses Geld müssen wir in
die Hand nehmen weil die Familien in
Berlin aber auch in anderen deutschen
Großstädten das war ja im Bericht zu
sehen verdienen gerade in den
Sommerferien jetzt auch sichere
Freibäder wo man sich erholen kann wo
man Spaß haben kann und keine Gewalt
schon angesprochen hat in deren
Kompetenzbereich das ganze Jahr fällt
sagt aber die Berliner Bäderbetriebe
sollen das Problem mal in den Griff
bekommen so ein bisschen sagen Sie es
auch mit ein bisschen mehr Unterstützung
macht die Innenministerin sich da die
inselnatorin sich da nicht ein schlanken
Fuß nein gar nicht die Bäderbetriebe
sind ja ein landeseigendes Unternehmen
und da nehmen wir jetzt einen Fluss
drauf da sind wir auch mit in der
Verantwortung aber die Bäderbetriebe
müssen jetzt konzentrieren die wir
gemeinsam mit den weder betrieben dann
durchsetzen es sind ja schon oftmals
sehen wir auch an den Bildern Männer mit
einer Migration Lebensgeschichte der
innenpolitische Sprecher der
Unionsfraktion sagt daher es sei ein
Integrationsproblem und beklagt eine
machokultur gehen sie da so pauschal mit
nein da würde ich nicht so pauschal
mitgehen schauen Sie wir haben diese
drei Bäder 1 also Neukölln eins ist in
Pankow und eins ist in Kreuzberg und da
haben sie ja viele Gäste dieser Beete
die Migrationshintergrund haben aber die
allermeisten verhalten sich richtig die
wollen einfach das warme Wetter genießen
und ein bisschen schwimmen und die sind
friedlich es ist eine kleine Minderheit
die ist männlich ja die hat auch häufig
Migrationshintergrund aber ich warne
davor hier zu pauschalisieren
der Sprecher der Gewerkschaft der
Polizei den ich vorhin schon nannte sagt
das sind Testosteron geladene Männer
aber jetzt muss man sagen wenn man noch
mal auf die Integrationsproblematik
schaut die der ähm
Sprecher der Unionsfraktion Ansprache
Integrationsprobleme in der zweiten
dritten Generation damit macht man sich
dann vielleicht auch ein bisschen zu
leicht haben Sie denn eine Erklärung
woher das kommt
ich glaube es häufig langeweile ist
Perspektivlosigkeit man weiß nicht so
richtig wo man selber hin will und hier
muss ein Bildungssystem ansetzen wir
müssen diesen jungen Menschen die dort
ja weil machen sich rumprügeln diesen
jungen Menschen müssen wir Perspektiven
geben und da müssen wir bei Bildung
ansetzen bei Präventionsmaßnahmen
einsetzen aber vor allen Dingen Chancen